La doctrina zombie que nunca parece morir,
por muy desacreditada que esté.
Quizás Uds. se hayan imaginado que la crisis financiera de 2008
hubiera podido desembocar en el colapso del neoliberalismo.
Después de todo, hizo evidentes sus características centrales:
la desregulación de los negocios y las finanzas,
derribando la protección pública,
empujándonos a una rivalidad extrema entre nosotros,
todo un poco defectuoso.
E intelectualmente, sí colapsó.
Y sin embargo, aún domina nuestras vidas.
¿Por qué?
Creo que la respuesta es que todavía no hemos creado
una nueva historia para reemplazarla.
Las historias son los medios con los que navegamos por el mundo.
Nos permiten interpretar sus complejas y contradictorias señales.
Cuando queremos entender el significado de algo,
no buscamos un significado científico,
sino fidelidad narrativa.
¿Lo que oímos refleja cómo esperamos que se comporten los humanos y el mundo?
¿Cuadra?
¿Progresa como debe progresar una historia?
Somos criaturas de la narrativa,
y una serie de hechos y cifras, por importantes que sean -
como saben, soy empirista, creo en hechos y cifras,
pero esos hechos y cifras no pueden desplazar una historia persuasiva.
Lo único que puede reemplazar una historia
es una historia.
No se le puede quitar la historia a una persona
sin darle una nueva.
Y no son solo historias en general con las que estamos sintonizados,
sino con las estructuras narrativas particulares.
Hay una serie de tramas básicas que usamos una y otra vez,
y en política hay una trama básica
que resulta ser tremendamente poderosa:
la llamo "la historia de la restauración".
Y es así:
El desorden aflige al mundo,
causado por fuerzas poderosas y nefastas,
que actúan en contra de los intereses de la humanidad.
Pero el héroe se rebelará contra este desorden,
luchará contra esas poderosas fuerzas,
contra todo pronóstico las derrocará
y restaurará la armonía al mundo.
Ya conocen esta historia.
Es la historia bíblica.
Es la historia de "Harry Potter".
Es la historia de "El señor de los anillos".
Es la historia de "Narnia".
Pero también es la historia
que ha acompañado a casi todas las transformaciones políticas y religiosas
por milenios.
De hecho, hasta podríamos decir
que sin una nueva y poderosa historia de restauración,
una transformación política y religiosa
quizás no pueda suceder.
Es así de importante.
Después de que la economía del "laissez faire" desencadenara la Gran Depresión,
John Maynard Keynes se puso a escribir una nueva economía,
y la historia de restauración que relató
fue algo así:
El desorden aflige al mundo,
(Risas)
Causado por las poderosas y nefastas fuerzas de la élite económica,
que han capturado la riqueza del mundo.
Pero el héroe de la historia,
el estado habilitador, apoyado por la clase trabajadora y la clase media,
combatirá ese desorden,
luchará contra esas poderosas fuerzas y redistribuirá la riqueza,
y gastando el dinero público en bienes públicos,
generará ingresos y empleo,
restaurando la armonía en el mundo.
Como todas las buenas historias de restauración,
esta resonó por todo el espectro político.
Los demócratas y los republicanos, los laboristas y los conservadores,
la izquierda y derecha,
todos se volvieron, en términos generales, keynesianos.
Y cuando el keynesianismo tuvo problemas
en los años 70,
los neoliberales, gente como Friedrich Hayek y Milton Friedman,
presentaron su nueva historia de restauración,
y fue algo así:
Nunca adivinarán lo que sigue.
(Risas)
El desorden aflige al mundo,
causado por las poderosas y nefastas fuerzas
del poderoso estado,
cuyas tendencias colectivizantes aplastan la libertad, el individualismo
y la oportunidad.
Pero el héroe de la historia, el emprendedor,
luchará contra esas poderosas fuerzas,
hará retroceder al estado,
creará riqueza y oportunidades,
y restaurará la armonía en el mundo.
Esta historia también resonó en todo el espectro político.
Los republicanos y los demócratas, los conservadores y los laboristas,
todos se volvieron, en general, neoliberales.
Historias opuestas
con una estructura narrativa idéntica.
Luego, en 2008,
la historia neoliberal se derrumbó
y sus oponentes se presentaron con...
(Risas)
¡nada!
¡Sin una nueva historia de restauración!
Lo mejor que podían ofrecer era un neoliberalismo diluido.
o un keynesianismo de microondas.
Y por eso estamos atrapados.
Sin esa nueva historia,
estamos atrapados con la vieja historia fallida
que sigue fallando.
La desesperación es el estado en el que caemos
cuando nuestra imaginación fracasa.
Cuando no tenemos una historia que explique el presente
y describa el futuro,
la esperanza se evapora.
El fracaso político es, escencialmente,
un fracaso de la imaginación.
Sin una historia de restauración
que nos pueda decir a dónde tenemos que ir,
no va a cambiar nada,
pero con esa historia de restauración,
casi todo puede cambiar.
La historia que necesitamos contar
es una historia que atraiga a la mayor cantidad de personas posible,
cruzando fallas políticas.
Debe resonar con profundos deseos y necesidades.
Debe ser simple e inteligible,
y debe estar basada en la realidad.
Admito que todo esto suena bastante difícil.
Pero creo que en las naciones occidentales,
en realidad hay una historia como esta
a la espera de ser contada.
En los últimos años,
hemos tenido una fascinante convergencia de hallazgos
en varias ciencias diferentes,
en psicología, antropología, neurociencia y biología evolutiva,
y todos nos dicen algo bastante asombroso:
que los seres humanos tenemos una capacidad inmensa de altruismo.
Sí, todos tenemos un poco de egoísmo y de codicia dentro de nosotros,
pero en la mayoría de las personas, estos no son nuestros valores dominantes.
Y también resultamos ser cooperadores supremos.
Sobrevivimos en las sabanas africanas, pese a ser más débiles
y más lentos que nuestros depredadores y que la mayoría de nuestras presas,
por una asombrosa capacidad para ayudarnos mutuamente,
y ese impulso de cooperar se ha programado en nuestras mentes
a través de la selección natural.
Estos son los hechos centrales y cruciales sobre la humanidad:
nuestro increíble altruismo y cooperación.
Pero algo salió terriblemente mal.
El desorden aflige al mundo,
(Risas)
Nuestra buena naturaleza fue frustrada por varias fuerzas,
pero creo que la más poderosa es la narrativa política
que domina estos tiempos,
que nos dice que deberíamos vivir en un individualismo extremo
compitiendo entre nosotros.
Nos obliga a luchar entre nosotros, a temer y desconfiar el uno del otro.
Atomiza la sociedad.
Debilita los lazos sociales que hacen que valga la pena vivir.
Y en ese vacío
crecen estas fuerzas violentas e intolerantes.
Somos una sociedad de altruistas,
pero estamos gobernados por psicópatas.
(Aplausos)
Pero no tiene por que ser así.
No es necesario,
porque tenemos esta increíble capacidad de unión y de pertenencia,
e invocando esta capacidad,
podemos recuperar esos componentes asombrosos de nuestra humanidad:
nuestro altruismo y cooperación.
Donde haya atomización, construyamos una vida cívica próspera
con una rica cultura participativa.
Donde nos encontremos aplastados entre el mercado y el estado,
podemos construir una economía que respete a las personas y al planeta.
Y podemos crear esta economía en torno a esa gran esfera descuidada:
el bien común.
El bien común no es ni mercado ni estado, ni capitalismo ni comunismo,
consta de tres elementos principales:
un recurso particular;
una comunidad particular que maneja ese recurso;
y las reglas y negociaciones que la comunidad desarrolla para administrarlo.
Piensen en una banda ancha comunitaria o en cooperativas de energía comunitaria
o en los terrenos comunitarios para cultivar frutas y verduras
que en Gran Bretaña son las huertas o parcelas comunes.
Un bien común no se puede vender, no se puede regalar,
y sus beneficios se comparten por igual entre los miembros de la comunidad.
Donde hemos sido ignorados y explotados,
podemos revivir nuestra política.
Podemos recuperar la democracia de quienes nos la quitaron.
Podemos usar nuevas reglas y métodos electorales
para garantizar que el poder financiero no vuelva a triunfar sobre el democrático.
(Aplausos)
La democracia representativa debe ser moderada por la democracia participativa
para que podamos refinar nuestras elecciones políticas,
y esa elección debe ejercerse tanto como sea posible a nivel local.
Si algo puede decidirse localmente, no debe determinarse a nivel nacional.
Y llamo a todo esto una política de pertenencia.
Creo que esto tiene el potencial de atraer
a una amplia gama de personas,
ya que unos de los muy pocos valores
que comparten la izquierda y la derecha
son la pertenencia y la comunidad.
Y podríamos referirnos cosas un poco diferentes,
pero al menos comenzamos con un lenguaje en común.
De hecho, mucha política puede considerarse una búsqueda de pertenencia.
Incluso los fascistas buscan comunidad,
aunque una comunidad espantosamente homogénea
donde todos se ven iguales y usan el mismo uniforme
y cantan los mismos eslóganes.
Lo que necesitamos crear es una comunidad basada en redes de conexión,
no redes de unión.
Una red de unión une a personas de un grupo homogéneo,
mientras que una red de conexión une a personas de diferentes grupos.
Y pienso que si creamos comunidades de conexión
lo suficientemente ricas y vibrantes,
podemos frustrar la necesidad de que la gente se sumerja en la seguridad
de una comunidad de vinculación homogénea
defendiéndose contra el otro.
En resumen,
nuestra nueva historia podría ser algo así:
El desorden aflige al mundo,
(Risas)
causado por las poderosas y nefastas fuerzas de las personas
que dicen que no existe la sociedad,
quienes nos dicen que nuestro mayor propósito en la vida
es pelear como perros callejeros por un cubo de basura.
Pero los héroes de la historia, nosotros,
nos rebelaremos contra este desorden.
Lucharemos contra esas fuerzas nefastas construyendo comunidades ricas,
atrayentes, inclusivas y generosas,
y de esta forma
restauraremos la armonía al mundo.
(Aplausos)
Y si creen o no que esta es la historia correcta,
espero que estén de acuerdo en que necesitamos una.
Necesitamos una nueva historia de restauración,
que nos guiará fuera del embrollo en el que estamos,
que nos cuenta por qué estamos aquí y nos dice cómo salir.
Y esta historia, si la contamos bien,
infectará las mentes de las personas en todo el espectro político.
Nuestra tarea es contar la historia que ilumina el paso hacia un mundo mejor.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)